And then they got this guy in Austin
who's working like doing 12-hour shifts
with Japan speaking fluent Japanese and
giving explanations and directing people
what to do, right? And I'm like, "What
do you mean, man? This is pretty easy to
I've never asked for any kind of
advanced like Japanese lessons or
anything like that. Like that's some
[ __ ] right?" Yeah, he he the guy
effed it up. Yeah, he he he that he's
screwed up. I that's not how you do
things.
>> No, but but you could even I I think I
bet I bet you could ask ask your CISO
like, "Hey, what would what did you guys
offer him? What was the offer to that
Indian guy as far as numbers go?"
>> I think it was somewhere around probably
probably 22 23 million something like
that.
>> He was going to get paid as much as you.
>> Yeah. But yeah, there there was no way
he was going to get that position.
>> But but but the fact it came down to you
and him,
>> that's ridiculous.
>> I know, right? They had to break old
protocol. Um the company has a rule that
you cannot snatch a person from a
different department. And they it
actually they had to break it because
Japan reached out to me first and said
please come over and then they had to go
to the CISO and my manager and then the
CISO had to be involved and said yeah
let's do it then no maybe not and then
because it's not the company way of
doing things they saw what I was doing I
said okay they're like [ __ ] it like send
a mortgage man said my manager said that
they said that they broke the entire
vertical. They didn't care. They're
like, "This guy could do it." They're
like, "Dude, I'm that old I'm doing this
age and stuff is speaking a Japanese. I
speak a Japanese to my dogs."
Um, other thing too, again, how many
times I tell you guys to get a books?
So,
um,
here
we're at where is your house, right?
This is one of my Azure administrator
books
>> in Japanese
>> nihongo day. And the fact that I could
just open it up and start reading it.
They're like, "Wow." They're like,
"Yeah, I don't need any Japanese
lessons. I'm good."
Right. Um, which one also did I Oh,
here. Want to have some fun?
I just put these over to the side. I'll
come back out. Wow. Look. Kubernetes.
O'Reilly book. Kubernetes in Japanese.
>> Oh, you got that book in Japanese. Oh,
wow. Okay.
>> Yeah, I got it in Japanese first,
English second,
then.
Oh, look. Terapform
a term book.
The fact that I have this in Japanese so
I can just sit here and start reading
it. The ISO 27001 books are still in the
other room. I don't have the 420001 yet
just came out.
>> Oh, no. I Okay, there. So, they did
print 421.
>> Yeah, I still still haven't gotten it
yet. Um I have to go pay for it. It's
going to be like $4500 just to get it.
>> Um but where did I put my money? I put
my money at these materials. I actually
read it. I'm not master of it, but I
actually knew what was going on. I can
actually talk about it. They're like,
"Cool, we need something like that,
right?" Um,
all I did is show up a little bit. It
wasn't that big. And so, for you guys
who have um for guys who are who have
imposter syndrome, I'm going to go
elaborate a little bit more of what what
Rob said. Um, when I first started this
program, again, remember I I paid for
everything in the beginning. I paid for
the Conclave. Um, the class was free.
there weren't anybody who was certified
except me.
And if those guys had imposter syndrome,
I can see that. But uh group one was one
of the hardest working groups that I had
and they they believed in what I had to
say and those guys got certified and got
jobs. Right? If you fast forward to
where we're at now, we have over 200
certified black men in the group
over 200.
We got black men on every single
continent right now the class except for
Antarctica.
Multiple languages,
multiple resources.
There are guys doing stuff that I don't
do at all. I have no idea. I'm not even
trying to control what they're doing. I
hear about it every once in a while,
right? I got specialists. I got a guy
making half million dollars a year just
doing AI class two.
If you have that mill and many
resources, you got free stuff, you got
nana, you got all kinds of [ __ ] in the
class, got all that, and then you have
imposter syndrome, it's on you, bro.
Don't Don't look at me.
Don't even look at me. Oh my god, man.
You is We have a therapist in the group.
Go talk to the therapist. We need to go
take care of that.
And yeah, other students to work with
too. Um the thing that I I find is again
my opinion is that as the as the class
continues, we have students who read
less who can read less. They read less
and they can read less. Their reading
comprehension level is decreasing. This
is right along with what BTS is saying.
And the guys who started in the
beginning, they were more hardcore.
They're more Gen X level and they're
just willing to put in the work. They
can read like a mother. They they ran
they read read all the time. It's how
much are you guys reading? It's what it
is. Gordon,
>> I'm I'm going to say this point to the
cows come home. Um, I have been
advocating this since my cohort of 5.5
and I advocate it to everybody that does
not have a regular personal reading
routine. I know there are some people
that like to read for pleasure, like
novels and things like that, that's
totally fine. Graphic novels, comic
books, all that counts. Great. If you're
not one of those people and you don't
read on a regular basis, I'm not here to
shame you. I'm here to give you a
strategy with your group or if you can
if you can just get one other person
read out loud.
I I I I am telling you that this is one
of the the easiest ways to not only get
over imposttor syndrome but to but to
also absorb information from books
rather quickly. Read the books out loud.
Don't give a [ __ ] about who's in the
room. Don't give a [ __ ] about who you
might offend. Just read out loud. And if
you can read with your group, even
better.
That is something that I that I did
along with my my brother uh my brothers
I should say Dax and Mr. B Hull um when
we first started in 5.5 and it it is a
regular practice of ours when we are
studying
and it's something that I highly advoc
advocate to any and all that have
difficulties or anxiety when it comes to
reading. Reading out loud will clear
that [ __ ] right up. Just be consistent.
And one of the the best ways to do it is
either by chapter or if it if it's if
the chapters are too long by page count.
So I'll read five pages, you read five
pages, the next person reads five pages.
While you're reading because you're
reading in an in uh informal setting,
you know, amongst, you know, your peers,
you can stop, you can ask questions, you
can look up things that'll increase your
comprehension of an understanding. Don't
be concerned about reading as fast as
humanly possible. Be concerned with
absorbing the information
because it would be great if you could
read a 100 pages an hour, but if you're
only comprehending 5% of that, I'd much
rather be the person that comprehends
80% of what I read and only read 25 to
30 pages. I'm getting a lot more done
that way.
>> Yeah. I just wanted to add what Gordon's
saying, too. He's he's right about the
reading out loud. It's a comprehension
technique that's used in music schools.
When I when I when I was studying my
music, that was actually a competition
um technique that they told us to do.
When we practice our instruments, we we
read our notes out loud. We sing out
loud. Sing the notes out loud even as we
playing the instruments. Next, say it
out loud. You recite your notes out
loud. That's actually a a common
learning technique in the music world. I
I just wanted just to throw that out
there.
Yeah, I did that also in Bible college
when um you know when we had to memorize
scripture, we just read it. I read it
out loud, you know, to myself and uh
just to try to memorize it. So yeah,
that does work, man. That's true.
>> So you guys can do it. You're not that
far away. I want to understand you're
not
just really just keep on going and then
when you get a job, keep on studying.
Don't stop and you'll be fine. I mean,
just keep on going. Yep.
Tell my man
just like I told you. I talk to the
admins and I'm probably have to marry a
Japanese woman now.
I won't be able to get away from it.
>> All right. All right. That's That's what
you
>> You're closing the loop. As as coach
said, you're closing the loop. Yeah, I'm
closing on.
Looks like I am.
All right, guys. Um, let's have some
fun. So, to the guys who have not
finished authorization um with with um
what's that technology called?
>> Cognito.
>> Cognito. That's right. The guys who
haven't done it yet, put a one in the
chat if you haven't completed the token
with Cognito. JJ is first. I know JJ
hasn't done it cuz he admitted it
already.
Jock, you didn't do it.
Really, Jacques?
I'm surprised you of all people. I can
see JJ. Okay, I know. All right. Um,
let's have you guys work on this
together. This is I'm
I'm trying to get a job. Yeah, you ain't
broke, Jack. You're You're We'll get you
in the job market. Okay. All right.
I can see I can see the next is um my
next class in November's got to be
Japanese. Like, please teach us
Japanese. Like, are you sure you want to
know? Like, do you want a human rights
violation?
Because for me, Japanese is really easy.
But that's because I did Russian first.
Russian's so hard. So, Japanese was
simple. Right.
Okay. Uh,
>> don't you have a Don't you got um a
Japanese teacher? Did you Did you have
to Did you get a Japanese teacher for
the the language group you made?
>> No. No, I No, I didn't get one there. I
should.
Yeah.
Well, I I will be I will be honest with
you though. Um again, just
go. So,
>> did I say that?
>> If if if it if it can't be recorded,
then
>> I'll say I I'll say it. So
>> when I was in Japan and I was in grade
school in Japan, I was in grade school a
few times in Japan. Um, one of my
teachers was really hot.
>> Yeah.
>> I wanted and then when I was in
university, one of my teachers was
really hot.
>> So
yeah, I really learned because if I did
it correctly, she would smile as she had
these dimples and I was like, "Oh, I
want to beg you." So, so it really
works. I remember that. So, I'll I'll
try to find a cute Japanese teacher.
Okay. I'll go find somebody be in the
group.
>> Yeah. Get god demotivation. It's not a
bad way to do it.
>> Yeah. Okay. So, JJ, why don't we have
why don't we start with you? Have you go
ahead and share your screen? Um
Jock, go ahead and also follow along
with us. We did get the token working.
uh the guys who have gotten it have
gotten the token working please work
with Jacques and JJ uh and then um
probably this weekend we're going to
start doing all of this in terraform
we'll see how far we'll see how far we
can do this just to be honest with you
the reason why I'm going slow on this it
I'm just going to be brutally honest
with you being able to do MFA and being
able to do a token with Cognto and being
able to talk about it competently at an
interview is gold
because not a lot of companies, not a
lot of people can do it. So, if you
could just talk the stepby-step process
of what what you did and you have the
knowledge about it, you're like, "Here
it is." They're going to be like, "Oh,
yeah, you're so great." So, I remember
doing cognto for the federal government,
I was going crazy. Yeah, I wanted to
die. So, again, I'm telling you guys,
this is what you really want to do. Go
for it. You'll be fine. Okay?
Um, I'm going to go ahead and back out,
sit here, watch you guys. Um, I should
probably drink a cold one, shouldn't I?
Yeah, sounds good. All right, I'll
watch. See you guys.
>> I I rather you do drink a cold one than
freaking Mountain Dew [ __ ] That's [ __ ]
for your heart.
Anyways,
all right. Y'all y'all work y'all work
work on with JJ. Um JJ, can y'all see
me?
Yep.
>> Okay, cool. All right. So, I'm assuming
the access to token is this one,
>> right?
>> Okay.
So, I uh made it a variable. Access
token is equal to all of that stuff.
But then when I I set up
uh Cognto and created a different stage
and gets for both of those
uh
and I set the
let's see where did I put it? Um,
authorizers,
>> excuse me, JJ.
>> Yep.
>> Hey, do you mind increasing the the size
of your two screens, the uh or the the
AWS console and the uh uh uh terminal
that you have.
>> Okay.
>> Appreciate it. Thank you. And Gordon,
and for anybody else to know, you can
increase it yourself. If you go up to
the uh two, three dots in Zoom, it'll
have you you can choose 150% 200%. So,
you can you can actually increase it
yourself. Just to let you guys know that
in Zoom.
>> That's good to know. Uh oh, there's a
>> Oh, not you. Not you. I'm talking about
the guys that are watching. like they
they can they can increase it on their
side so you so you don't necessarily
have to increase your own screen but
Okay.
>> Gotcha.
>> Okay. So,
so Okay. Let me scroll back up. And so
we did the I got the client ID, secret
hash,
did all that token M MFA, got the
session. Session is probably expired by
this point, but uh got the access token,
all this stuff,
and then made all of that a variable
somewhere.
Where did I do that?
Okay, so I did that here. Access token
equals
all that shindig
and then did the curl
against uh
that's where I messed it up. Hold on.
Okay, so I did no misspelled it here.
Okay, so here it is. This is where I
tried it. authorization colon access
token
D
and
it passed it successfully
somewhere. Authorization here pass the
token
but it still says
uh
still says 401. So that's
where I'm stuck.
Not sure why it didn't work
>> or to be precise unauthorized ex
exception like but I passed the token.
Why is it not going?
Anybody
>> go to
go to Cognito?
>> Okay.
Okay.
Okay. Userpool
app clients.
Click edit.
Okay. So you have
Okay.
Start over. Initiate off from from
scratch.
>> Okay. From the top.
>> Mhm.
cuz your um your session's definitely
expired unless you just ran it minutes
ago. So, might as well just do it all
over again.
>> Okay.
All right. Let me get
JJ. Did you extend the session time on
the GUI like I suggest?
Uh, it's atif. It's at 14 minutes.
>> Okay. Beautiful. Beautiful. Thank you.
>> I got to get that code.
A second.
Is that the phone?
Okay, clock starts now, I guess. So,
this is the access token.
Well, that's convenient.
Man,
that looks correct, right?
Y'all can see this
actually. Can I make this bigger?
>> Yeah, you're good.
>> Okay.
Message unauthorized.
I don't know why.
>> Time to check the logs.
>> Okay. Uh, cloud watch.
Here we go.
Well,
that's weird. Oh, this is from
this is Oh, never mind.
This is from
Yeah, these are old.
This is from April.
All the love. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah, these are all from April.
There are no logs.
Unless you're going to cloudfront
there's a laugh in All right.
Okay. Nothing in events.
That's not what I want to do. Um,
>> go back go back to your API
>> maybe dashboard here.
It's got two
That's just
>> metrics.
Okay, let's pause. Let's think this
over.
So, if you're getting
you're getting a 401 error.
Mhm.
>> Effectively, we're trying to figure out
why that is.
>> And there's no logs in Cloudatch.
>> Okay. Uh doesn't hit the lambdas,
>> right?
Use the terminal, guys. Use the
terminal.
Uh,
this is where I'd Google it because I
don't know. Um,
>> did you do the U did you create the
authorizer and everything already?
>> Yes, but let me double check it. Maybe I
messed it up. Um,
is this correct?
Token source authorization. Yep,
that's your user pool.
Yeah.
>> Yeah. Looks to be correct.
Uh JJ.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh go back to the console, please.
The API gateway.
>> Uh
yeah, one sec.
I mean just where you are right now
would be fine.
>> Yeah, click on that and then resources
on the left. All right. And then
click on the get method.
Uh
yeah, if you just uh scroll down a
little bit, I want to see the method
first.
Um Okay, that's correct. All right. I
just had a hunch. Um that's fine.
Yeah, it's fine. I was just making sure
that it's a the correct file that was
showing up, please.
Okay.
See, I'm not even I'm not getting this
back either. It just says unauthorized
exception.
Are we doing
all of this?
Okay.
Looks like it was passed. So, I don't
understand why it's not working.
Hey JJ, have you tried redeploying it
already?
Nope. I can do that. Hold on. Uh if it's
if that's it, I'm going to be mad.
>> Everything I mean, from what you've
shown me,
everything seems good. But
we do also have this option. And then we
have the terminal. Omar put some
commands in the chat. I don't know if
you saw those.
>> No, I did not. Okay, hold on.
Uh
Yeah, I was going to ask you to redeploy
the stage as well next. Um, so you
already just done that, I think. So
that's good.
>> Yeah, I just did it. Okay.
>> Yeah. Uh,
>> make sure you use the latest access
token run
this.
Uh, try test it now with the
with the fresh token
now that you've redeployed it.
Also, your um token like in terms of
your off time um did you extend it to 15
minutes or is it still on?
>> Yeah, 14 minutes. All right, that's
cool.
Is that still good?
I can't tell.
Oh, well that's interesting.
Is that
Unix next time?
Uh, probably is. Yeah, I'm guessing.
It's a time stamp of some sort.
Uh,
very likely.
>> So, according to this expires
May 12th, 8:55 p.m.
here, which is CST.
>> Okay.
>> So, I still have time maybe.
>> Yes. Yes. That means it hasn't expired
yet. Basically, that's the expiry
>> time stamp.
>> Okay,
>> it's supposed to be in the future.
That's fine.
>> Okay, so let me I redeployed it. Let's
see if it works.
>> Is there Is there a chance that you're
using the wrong user pool?
>> I only have one user pool.
>> You only got the one? Okay. Did you have
a previous one?
>> No.
same error, but let's check
uh that would be underco.
Yeah, I only have one.
Let me see. App clients
class group client ID 72 whatever.
And what do I have?
to zoom in on this editor. That sucks.
Nope, this one sucks.
Client secret hasn't changed.
It doesn't change, right? Client secret.
>> No, I don't think it should.
No, it doesn't. Okay. And then
does this show you
the user
and the password? Sure, that's fine.
That's correct.
Um,
yeah. I don't know.
That's the correct authorization token.
>> Uh I was going to ask you try and could
you maybe try and test it directly in
the uh API gateway portal?
>> Okay. Uh, how do you do that?
>> Uh, go to authorizes
uh class of authorizer.
>> Scroll to the bottom.
>> That is the bottom.
>> No, as in click on the glass.
>> Yeah. And then
>> put the access token here.
>> Yeah.
And then click test.
Okay.
Well, what the hell?
>> Okay,
I'll just do it again.
Do I do a new a new session or do I just
do the current session?
>> I think your current session is pretty
open
still.
>> Okay. I don't know how long ago you
started.
>> How much How much time do you have left?
You just got to check when the original
um ping went through cuz if you had 14
minutes and you're coming up on 10, you
might as well just restart it.
>> Start over.
>> You had the unit expiry stamp as well.
So if that is still
>> Yeah.
I'll just start over. Um,
okay. So, give me this one
and take all of this.
Ah, I've just let the I'm just reading
something here. It says that I think
you're supposed to use the IED token for
the console test instead of the access
token.
>> Okay, let me get there. Let me let me
get there and
look at what that is again.
>> The ID token will be one of the
responses
other than access
>> for me. Oh, actually it's in your uh
respond to or challenge succession JSON
JSON.
Okay. So it's not access token, it's
refresh token or ID token.
>> Yeah, that one. The ID token.
Take that ID token and just drop that
one in the console
and see where it comes up.
I've just got a hunch. I'm just testing
notches. I'm just showing 200. There
>> you go.
So why do they call it ID token when it
should be access token? Okay. Okay.
I was following the instructions and it
was wrong. It Okay,
now let's do that curl thing again.
Where is it?
Why won't you let me copy? What? What is
wrong with this computer now?
Okay. Correct.
>> Stupid.
>> All right. So, I think
>> I think it's specifically the um
specifically the API gateways like
built-in test u that requires the ID
token
from what I'm reading. So the curl will
accept the the access token
but the uh
>> the test authorizer button in the
console it only accepts the ID token.
It's a console limitation basically.
>> Okay. When I tried the access token, it
didn't work. But when I tried the ID
token, it works.
>> Yeah, I'm not sure why that is. I'm
still looking into that because
>> here I'll try the access token again.
See the one called access token doesn't
work.
The one called ID token works.
I mean, the access token should work in
the in the command, but I'm not sure
why.
>> I I don't know why it's not working.
>> Yeah.
>> Anybody?
Rob, Theo,
y'all still here?
>> I'm making you guys suffer through this.
>> Keep on trouble.
Okay. So, is this supposed to be access
token?
>> People who have done this, what what do
you say?
>> There's guys that have done this
already. Help them out.
>> What does the documentation say?
>> Okay. Uh
did Lambda run with no token? No. Where
was the request blocked? Cloudfront
basically.
What changed in the event?
You know what? Let me try.
They're both the same. Okay.
pull up the AWSI
documentation.
Okay. What am I looking for?
going to try to guide you a little bit,
but I'm driving.
>> Oh,
>> but you recall
the uh the document the two documents
that Aaron and Rob provided to us the
other day. Do you have that in your
links or does anyone can anyone drop
that form? But basically, what commands
are you running? You want to look that
up in the documentation and read what it
says and understand what values it's
passing
>> the cognto stuff.
>> Yes, sir. So, what command are you
running?
Uh, give me a second. Give me a second.
>> Um, the first one is initiate off and
the second is respond to off challenge.
So, look those up right there in the
documentation. You should see the uh the
all commands there
and you should be able to understand and
break down which what which each one of
those phrases in the command
is referring to.
Am
I missing something?
So here's the example three. Respond to
a software token challenge. Software
token MFA.
This is what the output spits out.
Not using device key.
So here's access token. Here's refresh
token. Here's ID token.
And then their example access refresh
and ID are almost exactly the same
down.
Did you see Bash's link?
Uh, give me a second.
It's not cute.
After creating the user pro authoriz you
can test invoke it with an identity
token. You cannot use an access token.
for authorization scopes. Enter one or
more full names of the scope that has
been configured
when the pool was created.
entire method call succeeds if any scope
that is pushed on the scope.
Is this it right here
guys?
Uh, I mean you can give a go. Uh, she
can be doing some reading. Just go and
download
one or more full names of a scope that
has been configured.
I don't know what that means.
I mean uh it works. You have actually
fixed this in a sense like the ID token.
It runs with the ID token, right? It
just doesn't run with Right.
>> Okay, cool. We're just trying to figure
that out. Okay.
>> Yeah, we're trying to figure out why it
doesn't work with the access token.
I was following the instructions in
Berica
and it doesn't where did I put baller.
Uh
this is rest action boy prod
um
I don't know this is Bash I think Bash
put this in here there's a screenshot
and the text is highlighted in orange
about the access token
>> uh
you put it in chat that.
>> Uh, yes. I think that's the most recent
one that's in there.
>> Is he sharing his screen or is he
>> No, I'm just looking in the chat here.
There's a screenshot.
>> I'm not seeing any screenshots.
>> JJ, going to the threat. Going to the
last threat.
Okay. And at the very very bottom
there's Joe Talver Jr. Share the link.
Keep going.
That that is the bottom link.
All right. That's
there's more there for me. But basically
it says in the documentation it says um
after creating the cognto user pools
authorizer you can test uh invoke by
supplying it with an identity token
that's provisioned from the user pool.
You can't use an access token to test
invoke your authorizer.
>> Yeah we did that earlier.
>> Oh okay.
>> So so okay. So then when you pass it
through curl, what the identity token
works but not the access token,
>> right? So it's saying you can't use the
access token.
>> Um
>> is the way I'm interpreting this.
>> It's only for the testing vote. Um
that's the way I interpret it
personally. It's only for that testing
vote that you can't use.
>> Oh, okay.
>> Yeah. So
>> Oh, okay. Only for the test. Okay. I see
it says only for the test. Okay.
>> Okay. So then how do you use it?
>> Never mind
>> in production.
>> I mean what I could see should be you
could use both in a sense. Um
>> well I just tried
>> they do separate things essentially in
it. So
the ID token says that it's like it it
verifies your ID, who you are and then
the access token uh verifies your right
your eligibility to actually access.
>> So it's okay. So
>> let me
decode the both of them and see what
they say.
Okay, here's ID token.
So, access token is different. There's
different JSON in here.
Um, we might have to configure a custom
scope, but I'm going to I was really I'm
looking into like what you found in that
section that was talking about the
picture scopes.
>> So, I'm just trying to figure out how
exactly that works in the console. Um,
but yeah, we may have to do that cuz
technically
we should be using the access token. Um,
not the ID token. But, uh, I'm just
trying to figure out how we do that in
the console.
Where was I reading that? This to use an
access token. Do the following. Yeah,
>> one or more full names of a scope that
has been configured when the Amazon can
use user pool was created.
For example, following the example and
create a user pool for rest, one of the
scopes is the URL.
At runtime, the method call succeeds if
any scope that is specified on the
method in this step matches the scope
that is claimed in the incoming token.
Otherwise, it fails for the 41
unauthorized. I think that's what's
happening basically.
>> It was in English,
>> but that's all I can tell you.
>> I mean, that's what's happening. I think
that we're getting a 401 on authorized
response right now, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So, I think this is actually
happening in the background. So
uh we need to implement
that authorization workspace. So
um we need to add a customs code for
just trying to figure that out.
Okay. So if I go back to
API authorizer,
shouldn't there be an option for this
somewhere?
Yeah, there is. It's just trying to
figure it out. So
like this isn't a value. This is
See the access token is token colon use
access scope here.
Lighty token doesn't have that.
Sorry, say I was reading something.
>> U
looking at the cut the outputs from
decoding it. The access token has
different fields. It has token use
access scope equals cognto and uh the ID
token doesn't have that information.
>> Yep.
That's the only uh
scope token that you're going to get
with that method, that challenge.
So,
other
that's the only user pool I have.
So method request that is
Does this matter right here? Authoration
scope.
Um, no, not not
that I can see. Not right now.
Just put in.
Okay.
The header for the access token has the
same structure as the ID token.
Signs access tokens with a different key
from the key that signs ID tokens.
the header contains two pieces of
Okay.
How do I use this
What if it's really that stupid?
Uh, what if it's what? How stupid? I was
reading something.
Didn't you already do that?
>> No, I just did authorization, not
authorization colon bearer.
>> What?
Maybe give it a go.
Can just try guess
see what happens. Be inexpensive for us.
Did I spell that right?
Authorization bear your access token.
Nope.
No difference.
Yeah, I don't think it was going to make
a difference.
If you want to use access
uh ID, I think you have to configure
your app client for o.
Okay. So right here um
what about part C where it says for
cognitive choose a region use a stage
variable to define your user pool.
Use the following format for your user
pool.
>> That would be I mean you only got the
one user I
>> does that make any sense here? No. This
is
helpful.
Okay. Where did it say that?
Okay. authorizers.
So they're look it what are they talking
about?
>> Well, you confused them.
>> For Cognto user pool, choose the AWS
reason you created the pool and select
an available. Okay,
you can use a staged variable name.
I don't think we're doing that. All
right. Create authorizer. After
creating, you want to test invoke
identity token as provided. Cannot use
this access token to invoke the
authorizer. You can obtain this identity
token by doing blah blah blah.
The procedure creates a user pull
authorizer that uses the created
to configure
To use an identity token,
do the following. Keep authorization
scope empty.
Okay.
To use an access for authorization
scope, enter one or more full names of a
scope that has been configured
when the pool was created.
What does this mean?
Well, if you read a little bit further
down there, this is the reason why I'm
thinking that
or off, we need to configure or off. If
you go past step six, no, no, it just go
a little bit further down the page. See
after step six yet see where it says
with the cognito usable authorizer if
the O of scopes option isn't specified
the API gateway treats the supply token
as an as an identity token
and verifies the claimed identity is the
one from the user group.
Okay. So if you don't provide a scope
option then it uses the identity token.
Uh yeah, essentially.
>> So where do you supply the scope option?
>> That's the thing I'm trying to look into
right now, which is actually configuring
your app plan to use both
instead, which is not doing it well. So,
we're going to method request settings.
Okay. So,
well, are active. Bummer.
Yes. So from what I understand here to
use the access um ID you would need to
set up you would need to configure
oaf and you need to use the custom
scopes
but right now I mean you're doing fine
with the ID token. ID token does return
like correctly. Um
so I mean it works with the ID token but
if you want to set up the access token
it's more like production pattern. Um
and if you have like a real
web architecture
this would be the proper
uh flow which is to use the access ID
basically.
So if you want to get production with it
that kind of pattern then you'd have to
do the Google
>> I would need to add the full name of the
scope.
>> Okay.
I feel like I'm right on the edge of
figuring this out.
I'm just going to take this
and stick it in here.
See if that made makes any sense.
Save.
redeploy.
Oops.
How much time do I have left on this
token?
14 minutes.
So, I got one more
shot at this.
Write
this down.
Yeah.
>> Yeah. It's definitely what I said when
uh it's you have to actually set up both
which you haven't got set up. So,
>> well, it did what it said to do and it
still didn't work.
>> Yeah, this is why. So, um
it works with ID ID. Yeah.
The the ID token.
Okay. I don't know. It
I don't understand what
I did what it said and it still doesn't
work.
Unless I'm not understanding what it's
trying to tell me.
And
Okay.
How do I get to this part?
Okay. So, go back to user pools.
User pools.
Domain.
I don't have any domains.
Yeah, that's
>> that's called the I was talking about.
Um,
>> so
as far as I'm aware,
>> what do they want for this value?
Note to configure resource identifiers
and custom scope names you need to
construct the access scope full names
for OATH scopes which is used by code's
pools authorizer.
>> Yeah, go to that page.
>> Please make s English sense of that.
So that's where we are. So you have to
create
Yeah.
Is there an option for create a resource
server?
>> Uh, go scroll down.
>> There you go. Create resource.
>> This is all the way down. Okay, let's
try it. Uh,
just enter a name.
The resource server is an integration
between your user pool and the API. H
resource server as a custom scope that
you must activate in your app client.
When you configure the resource server,
your app can generate access tokens to
OS scopes that authorize rewrite
operators.
Enter a friendly name for the res. I
don't have a resource server.
>> It looks like you're just creating it.
So you can name it whatever you want.
>> Yeah, it looks like you're making it
there. So you just gave it a name uh a
name.
Okay. Identifier
Not a great name.
>> Class resource server name.
>> I think
>> let's go back to that. Yeah, I think in
that screenshot they had a custom scope.
So, they added a custom scope.
>> Okay. Did I not do that?
>> I think you can still edit it there,
can't you?
>> Yeah. This the edit button wasn't
disabled. Right. Yeah.
>> Okay. Right there. Okay. This edit.
>> I don't even care what the name is.
Uh,
I don't know if that means anything. Um,
just let it go is the scope name.
What? I go back.
>> Are you following any name
>> any process for this or you just kind of
just winging it at the moment?
>> I'm winging it at this point if I'm
being honest. Um
I'm just like, you know what? Let's just
see if this works. Um
yeah.
No, no. What I wanted is uh resources
maybe.
Okay. So,
this scope and have this scope just
bloody go.
I don't know if that does anything.
And
do the same thing for
you.
and then redeploy again.
will this work? I don't know.
survey says
nope.
>> All right. I don't know.
>> All right. So, I think that your
your authorization
>> maybe
probably expired by now. Who knows?
>> No, I mean it has to like say that
because of what you chose.
as in the console. Yeah.
>> 9:18. I have four minutes to find out
how to fix this before I do the thing
from the top.
>> Are you hearing me? Uh, go to the
console, bro.
>> Where you want me to go? Go back to the
console where you put in the scopes.
>> Okay.
>> No, not there as in like in the um the
>> API.
>> Yeah, the API,
>> right?
>> Oh, this is
>> okay.
>> Yeah, change that.
Not just bloody good. Change it to CS
server
slash just bloody go. I'll put it in the
chat.
>> Okay.
>> Oh,
where is my mouse? Well, that's your
mouse, not my mouse.
Also, just make sure that the uh
>> like that.
>> Yeah. What does your one say? Does it
say CR7 or C7R?
Make sure it says
uh
>> I put
C7R server
R.
All right. Yeah, just put that
add that to both.
Yeah. See
and then deploy API.
You ready to change it?
Nope.
I'm going to try one more thing.
It expired. So, I'm going to do the
whole shindig again.
Okay. Access token.
E token.
How much time do I have?
till 10:19. Cool.
Now,
Don't think I need
great now.
Okay.
I don't think this is it.
That is what I did.
We have scope.
Yeah, that's the that's the default
scope. It's not a custom scope.
That's the defense. Can
>> I just put that in as the scope? Would
that be stupid?
>> It wouldn't make any difference. It
wouldn't help you anything.
>> You sure?
>> Give it.
>> I'll I'll give it a whirl.
>> Just like Theo likes to say, you're
free. You know, you can do whatever you
want.
Free.
>> You are free. You're free. I'm not here
to I'm not here to limit you. I'm just
here to watch.
I don't think this will make any
difference, but let's find out.
>> I would be very surprised if it did cuz
you're adding it as a custom scope and
that's actually the default scope with
API with trying to do a direct API call
we're doing.
>> It would be stupid if it worked. That is
all I'm saying.
deploy
two.
Don't care.
Okay.
Mother,
it works.
>> Okay.
>> You say, "Does that work?"
That works.
>> How? Why?
>> Let me put Python just to be sure.
Hello from work. Yeah,
just
>> so what was the final answer to?
>> This is so stupid. Okay, I will show
you. Um, where did I put it? Under
resources.
>> Okay.
And you go to your method,
>> edit,
>> add authoration scope.
>> So it it was the um default one.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, no.
>> You have to explicitly say the default
scope in order for
>> Okay. I know for the custom ones you
could do whatever it is and then like
read write or ad man. Okay, so you have
to actually put the Wow, thanks
>> stupid.
>> No, but hold up hold up. The access
token um is that your access token or
did you update that um that variable?
>> No, no, let let me let me double check.
Let me before I proclaim victory in the
name whatever.
>> Uh
>> actually using your ID token instead of
your access token or like
>> No, no, I'm using I'm using the access
token.
>> Okay.
>> Let me scroll up and look. Okay.
Okay. So, access token is ey blah blah
blah
3 IQ. Access to EY blah blah blah B3 IQ.
And then ID token is EJ whatever ends
with UKW
and uh ID token is blah blah blah blah
blah UKW. So yeah I am using the access
token.
>> Okay.
>> So uh let me write that down real quick.
Uh
so under
where did I put this nonsense
method requests
>> it's under yeah it's under method
request
is a method edit method request
I think and then Here
date.
Okay.
Thank you everybody. That was class
essentially.
I'm done.
>> I took the whole class. I'm sorry.
>> That's No, that's all right. It's That's
>> It didn't work.
>> That's what we're here for.
>> It works.
>> This is I would rather you come here and
participate and get it done during the
session like this than for you to be
quiet
because there's nothing we can do if
you're quiet.
But if if you talk and participate, I'll
I'll always have time for students who
do this. Yeah. Then you probably get
then you probably get uh job later on.
You make money. Then you can go on some
podcast and call people [ __ ] for
discounting my class.
Just go.
So this is what we're here for. All
right. Uh, Jock, you're next up on
Saturday. Okay.
>> Okay.
>> Uh, but I think people all learned
something. I like how you did this. I
like how you suffered. I like how you
worked hard. Um, I like a lot of this.
This is actually really good. I think
you did a great job. You want to be up
too, Kev? On Kevin? Really? You too.
Okay. So, Jock and Kevin, both of you on
Saturday. All right. Okay.
>> So,
>> what
>> I could just understand why this worked.
Yeah. Is this because it's the default
scope is still a valid scope. So, it
actually accepts the default scope.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. It should that it's along those
lines basically. Yeah. It the default
should work. Uh there shouldn't be a
reason. Yeah.
Uh, I think it's my best guess.
>> Sometimes I look at this within myself,
I'm like, uh, I don't know. But it
worked, right? So,
>> yeah. Yeah, it works. It actually works.
Okay. I'm surprised at that. But, I
mean, uh, it it makes sense. It's a
default scope is actually went under one
of the accepted.
It's It's an accepted
>> kind of like
>> it's valid. Okay.
>> It's kind of like dating a modern woman
and everything is going well. You're
like, how the HELL THAT HAPPENED?
OKAY,
>> THAT ACTUALLY WORKS.
>> YEAH,
>> it works only as far as if you want to
actually use custom scopes, you still
have to set up like the way you have to
actually go the the way of setting u
configuring o with the app client. But
um it also accepts the default scope.
It's within the documentation.
I mean it is what it is.
All right.
>> Can I ask a quick question?
>> Yep. What's up?
>> So, well, he I was behind, but he went
to uh JJ, you went to methods and then
you created a method and then the
method. Go ahead.
>> Let me go back. Okay. Okay. So, I went
to let's say for node. It's the same for
Python, but you go to uh let me go down
to you method request settings and you
hit edit
>> and you add the authorization scope of
the default authorization scope, which
is why that's not set as default,
whatever. But I put that in there and
hit save.
>> Okay. Save. Okay. You went to you went
to node. You went to method method
request settings. You hit edit. You went
to authorization.
You specified your cognto. And then
>> Yep.
>> Okay. And then after um um authorization
scopes,
>> yeah, you put in aws.cognito.signit.
You know what? Let me copy and paste it
into the chat. Hold on.
Uh
you got to put this
as your authorization scope.
I could just get the mouse over there.
>> And you and you selected API key
required.
>> No,
>> it's just a
>> Yeah, I left that blank. The only thing
I added was the authorization scope.
>> Everything else I left alone.
>> Thank you.
>> You're welcome.
Yeah. So mechanically this is valid.
Yeah. But it doesn't actually it's
basically almost the same thing. You're
using the default scope. So it's like
you're not using any custom scope at
all. So
>> I don't know. Do you get what I mean,
JJ? Like it's like you're using
>> Yeah. There's nothing custom. I'm just
explicitly using the default.
>> Yeah. So, it's like mechanically this
works. So, you found a hack basically.
So, shout out to you. Um, but it's
almost the same as not using a scope at
all cuz you're just using the
>> I mean, uh, shout out to the person who
figured out the echo thing with the base
64 because I looked back at the token. I
was like, "Okay, what token does this
scope want?"
And then it clicked. I was like, "This,
you know what? Let me throw that in
there and see what it does.
>> Yeah.
>> Where did
Where did I see the last? Yeah, it says
here scope.
>> So, I was like, well, if you want the
scope, I'm gonna give you this scope and
see what it mean.
>> Yeah, but that's reductive. Do you get
what I mean? It's like it's weird.
>> Yeah. It's redundant. It's
>> redundant. Yeah.
>> Round circles. I'm like,
>> you've closed the loop on it, bro.
You've closed the loop on it. But I
mean, uh, yeah, [ __ ] it, bro. Hack I
like hacks as well, man. I like hacking
[ __ ] So, uh, yeah, this is good. This
works in sense, but it's not a
production pattern. Like, you can't do
this at work. Like, this is not going to
work. So, but
>> I don't know what people at work would
do, honestly.
I wonder if someone's actually posted a
medium or a substack about this. I'd be
interested.
Like, has anyone else reached run into
this problem or are we the first?
>> No, I'm sure other people have run into
the problem, but they won't be able to
um sort of frame it eloquently as you're
going to be able to do if you write that
that post
cuz the the wounds are still fresh for
you. So I would go.
>> All right.
>> So um on that point, check out the the
link to Stack Overflow that Kevin found.
>> Okay.
>> In the chat.
>> All right. Let me see.
address. Get over here.
>> Got like 300 tabs open, but whatever.
Uh, let's read it.
Oh, that's a good question.
And this is why I said it was a bit back
cuz it's like what? Well, um, yeah,
it's cool.
You know what? One more. I like Okay,
what if I take off
Where's my notes? What if I take off
bear? I don't know if that makes any
difference.
Is that
nope, don't have to have bear. Okay,
interesting.
uh
authorizes the augmented user disauor
the bearer of of an access token to
query and update all information about a
user p with get user when you
authenticate your user with the API.
This is the only scope you receive in
the access token. is only the only scope
you need to read and write access user
attributes that you authorized your app
client to read and write. You can also
request this scope and request to your
authorized endpoint. This scope alone
isn't sufficient to request user
attributes from the user info point for
access tokens to authorize both user
pools and user
must request both the scope's open ID
and this and off to authorize request.
Okay.
So, if you want more information about
the user, you have to request the open
ID scope.
Whoa. Okay. I don't know
if we're doing that.
No, that's that's the custom scope state
that I was talking about. So that is
okay.
>> Yeah, that's part of the the
>> Yeah, that's probably
I don't think we're doing that right
now. Are we? I don't know if we're going
that deep.
>> Okay.
All right.
Who wants to go next?
>> We ain't going next today. No.
>> Yeah, it's it's a wrap for the day. We
we'll continue Saturday.
>> That's right. Wrap of the day. I like
that expression. So, um
>> good work. I like what you guys did.
>> Um JJ, you got you got to help people
out on Saturday, right?
>> Uh not available on Saturdays, but um
>> see
I have a baseball.
available on Saturday. So,
>> you're you're you're Why aren't you
available on Saturday?
>> It's the Sabbath. Friday evening to
Saturday evening, Jesus time.
>> Oh, okay. Fine. That's fine. That's
acceptable. I understand that. How about
Sunday?
>> Maybe. Yeah.
>> Okay. Yeah.
>> So, Sunday you're coming back and you're
helping out.
>> Sure. What What time on Sunday?
>> You know what the time is?
>> I'll have to look at
>> what you're on Facebook. Yeah.
>> All right.
>> I get you. All right. We'll see you in
front. We'll see you this weekend.
Anyway, good job everyone else. You did
a great job. I like what I see.
You're you're you're one step closer,
everyone. Okay, let's get going.
>> So, one more one quick question. You
were okay with me using Gemini in front
of everybody. I don't
>> I don't mind how you did it.
>> Okay.
>> Because you're you're already thinking
and then you're using it for
troubleshooting. That's how I use it.
>> Okay.
>> But if you're like, I don't know
anything, so how do I use Cognito or
what's a token?
like, "Oh, you're in student mode."
Okay, so that's if you're doing
everything professionally, you shouldn't
be doing that. That's just not in the
office. You don't do that. But if you're
like, if you got Stack Overflow open and
then you have Gemini open too, you got
some books open, you're like, I'm trying
to figure this out and people like,
yeah, we get you. Yeah, that's that's
fine. That's that's what I do. I got
plenty of trouble with with with Tati PT
over different stuff that I'm doing. Um
I
so the error message we had last week
with the um what was that? What was I
forgot what it was? I have to go back
through it. But there's a huge error
message you guys had. I did not. So I
went back to chatt and said how did this
error message happen? Like why why did
they have it? But I didn't. We had to go
through the combo because I didn't know
why where it came from right and we we
got through it. So that's kind of
normal. All right.
>> Okay.
>> Cool.
>> Anyway, you did a great job and I will
see you next week. Okay.
>> Next week.
>> All righty.
>> Great.
>> Congratulations again. Well done. Well
done.
>> Yeah. Congrats.
>> Good job. I'm
>> giving you a slow clap.
>> Japanese cup. Yeah. See you guys. Well
done.